Uh oh.
You just fell into a pool.
With this thing.
This is WHAT IF, and
here's what would happen
if you fell into a spent nuclear fuel rods.
This is a spent nuclear fuel pool.
And you've just accidentally fallen into it.
But what exactly is this thing?
This large pool of water
is meant to cool spent fuel rods
after they come out of a nuclear reactor.
While powering a nuclear reactor,
these fuel rods become very, very hot.
We're talking 2,800°C (5,092°F).
After it's spent 3 to 6 years inside of a nuclear reactor,
a fuel rod is no longer efficient.
Problem is, it still emits plenty of harmful radiation,
and it will for the next 10,000 years.
Even though it's trash, there's not
a garbage dump in the world that will accept it.
So, why is water a good
place to put these things?
Not only does the water spend several
decades cooling the fuel rods, but
it also affects their radiation.
The water essentially acts as a biological shield
with hydrogen absorbing and
deflecting the radiation bouncing against it.
This makes it completely safe for you
to stand near the pool with no ill effects.
But what happens if you fall into the water?
As soon as you orient yourself, you'll
quickly notice the temperature of the pool.
This big tub of water won't be the refreshing
dip you're looking for on a hot summer day.
Instead, it'll be around 30°C (86°F).
So a bit colder than your
average hot tub but still very warm.
Let's hope you didn't accidentally turn
off the water flow as you're falling into the pool.
If you did, then you'd be in some serious trouble.
Spent nuclear fuel pools
are constantly cycling out water
in order to keep it at a cool enough temperature.
Remember these fuel rods are incredibly hot.
And if the water isn't cycled out, then
it would heat up significantly
and slowly evaporate over time.
Resulting in you, burning to a crisp.
But that didn't happen, so now that
you're starting to swim in this hot pool of water,
when does the horrible
radiation poisoning kick in?
Or when do you turn green
and start to gain superpowers?
These are the sort of things
that are supposed to happen
when you fall into something
that has nuclear fuel in it right?
Not exactly.
Although that sounds like fun,
it wouldn't happen if you were to
fall into a spent nuclear fuel pool.
That's because of the water.
Not only does it protect
the people outside of the pool.
It'll also protect you if you happen to fall inside one.
As long as you don't swim several
meters underwater to touch the fuel rods,
you'd be completely fine.
In theory, you could swim in this pool
until you looked like a raisin
without feeling any negative effects.
Although they're protecting
something incredibly dangerous,
spent nuclear fuel pools
are quite serene and kind of boring.
In fact, this might be a lot cleaner
and safer than your average public pool.
You won't find any germs
or children peeing in the water here.
Swimming in this pool would expose you to less
radiation than you experience in your everyday life.
We encounter radiation in medical
procedures such as X-rays and CT scans.
From certain fuels like gas or coal;
even our televisions and other electronic
screens give off tiny traces of radiation.
Swimming in here isn't any more
dangerous than watching a WHAT IF video.
If splashing around in a spent
nuclear fuel pool is too boring for you,
how about swimming on one of Saturn's moons?
That sounds like a story for another WHAT IF.